[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT'S CALLED MENTAL
ILLNESS IF I'M NOT CORRECT.
>> Tucker: PIERS MORGAN
JOINS US.
>> HEY, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS POLITICAL PUNDIT AND
DISMISSAL OF --
>> I FIND IT ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS THAT WE ARE EVEN
HAVING TO DISCUSS OMAROSA IN
ANY SERIOUS POLITICAL
CONTEXT OF THE ONLY REASON
WE ARE DOING THAT WAS
BECAUSE SHE WAS ALLOWED TO
HAVE AN OFFICE IN THE WEST
WING OF THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
NEARLY A YEAR.
I DON'T KNOW WHY DONALD
TRUMP WOULD HAVE EVER LET
HER IN THERE.
SHE IS ALREADY BEHAVING
EXACTLY HOW I COULD HAVE
PREDICTED SHE WOULD BEHAVE.
IN OTHER WORDS, SQUEALING
LIKE A CANARY AND TAKING
THEM ALL DOWN AS, OF COURSE,
SHE IS GOING TO.
SHE IS ONLY ROSA.
SHE IS A REALITY TELEVISION
STAR WHOSE ONLY TO BE
POISONOUS VIPER SPREADING
GOSSIP, INEND DOUGH AND
TERRORIZING EVERYONE IN HER
WAKE.
FIRST QUESTION, WHAT WAS SHE
DOING THERE?
>> Tucker: I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE.
>> I MEAN, SERIOUSLY.
>> Tucker: RUSSIAN STORY
THIS IS A BIGGER SCANDAL.
OMAROSA WORKED IN THE WHITE
HOUSE?
REALLY?
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T EVEN
NOTICE.
I GUESS SHE SEEMS NORMAL TO
THEM, I GUESS, I DON'T KNOW.
>> QUI HAVE
>> WUI HAVE
>> WEI HAVE
>> WE HHAVE
>> WE HAVVE
>> WE HAVEE
>> WE HAVE ALL THIS STUFF
PORTER.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THERE
EITHER GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT HIM.
QUESTIONS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT TO THE
TOP ABOUT WHO KNEW WHAT
WHAT, WHEN, AND WHERE.
IF WE ARE GOING TO APPLY
THAT LOGIC AND JUDGMENT TO
ROB PORTER.
WHERE WAS THAT JUDGMENT
ABOUT OMAROSA WITH HER OWN
OFFICE IN THE WEST WING?
IT IS ALMOST BEYOND PARODY.
THERE IS A SERIOUS POINT TO
THIS, TUCKER, WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT SURROUNDING
HIMSELF WITH?
I HAVE KNOWN DONALD TRUMP A
LONG TIME.
WHEN I TOOK PART ON
CELEBRITY APPRENTICE WITH
ONLY ROSA.
HE HAS TO HAVE BETTER PEOPLE
AROUND HIM IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, I THINK, THAN THE
TYPES OF PEOPLE WE SEE WITH
ROB PORTER AND OMAROSA.
>> Tucker: I THINK OMAROSA
IS PROBABLY IN HER OWN
CATEGORY.
I CAN SAY, YOU KNOW, HAVING
BEEN OVER THERE A FEW TIMES
IT'S NOT CHOCK-FULL OF
OMAROSAS.
SHE DID WORK THERE SHE
BECAME FAMOUS FOR BEING
HORRIBLE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
YOU WORKED WITH HER ON THE
APPRENTICE.
WHAT'S SHE LIKE?
>> SHE IS ABSOLUTELY
APPALLING.
I MEAN, LITERALLY ONE OF THE
EVER ENCOUNTERED IN MY LIFE.
I HAVE ENCOUNTERED A LOT OF
BAD PEOPLE.
SHE HAS NO SAVING GRACE.
SHE WAS VICIOUS, CONNIVING,
SCHEMING, PLOTTING,
TREACHEROUS.
SHE -- I MEAN HER FIRST
GAMUT TO ME DAY ONE FIRST
CHALLENGE.
SHE SIDE ARMS UP TO ME HEY,
PIERS WE SHOULD HAVE A
SHOWMANCE EVERYONE ON THE
APPRENTICE HAS SEX TOGETHER
AND WE COULD SELL THAT AND
MAKE LOTS OF MONEY.
I SAID ARE YOU COMPLETELY
DILUTED?
PLEASE, GO AWAY.
SHE SAID WHAT'S THE MATTER
WITH YOU ARE YOU GAY?
I SAID NO, JUST BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO HAVE SEX WITH
YOU ON THIS SHOW IT DOESN'T
MAKE ME GAY.
I'M A VICTIM OF OMAROSA,
TUCKER.
BUT SHE GAVE ME THEN FOR
FOUR OR FIVE WEEKS
UNRELENTING FIVE BARRELS OF
ABUSE, TIRADES, HOMOPHOBIC
STUFF AND REALLY VICIOUS,
NASTY STUFF.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
SHE GOT BEATEN ON THE SHOW.
I ENDED UP WINNING IT.
THAT STUCK IN HER MIND AS
WELL.
COME FORWARD TO THE CAMPAIGN
MIDDLE OF 2017.
SHE IS GOING TO BE WORKING
FOR DONALD TRUMP THE
CANDIDATE.
WHAT?
HOW CAN THAT EVEN MAKE ANY
SENSE.
THEN I HEAR WHEN HE WINS SHE
IS GOING TO BE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
NOW, LOOK, AGAIN, I HAVE A
LOFT RESPECT FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
BUT I'M AFRAID WITH OMAROSA
THIS MADE NO SENSE AT THE
TIME.
IT MAKES NO SENSE NOW SHE
HAS LEFT.
SHE APPARENTLY ACHIEVED
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN HER
TIME IN THE WHITE HOUSE
OTHER THAN DISRUPTING
EVERYBODY.
AND YOU CAN JUST BET YOUR
LIFE SHE WAS THERE
SCHEMING, PROBABLY TAPE
RECORDING.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO HAVE
CELEBRITY BIG BROTHER AND
ALL THIS STUFF WILL COME OUT
OF THIS.
THEN WE WILL HAVE THE BOOK
AND THEN THE DOCU SERIES AND
LIFETIME MOVIE, TUCKER AT
WHICH POINT YOU AND I WILL
HAVE TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY SO
RIDICULOUSLY ABSURD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: THAT'S ONE OF THE
MOST VIVID DESCRIPTIONS OF
ANYONE I HAVE EVER HEARD.
HAVE YOU BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH HER?
I SUPPOSE YOU ARE NOT
TEXTING EACH OTHER.
>> WE HAVE NOT STAYED IN
TOUCH.
DID I BUNCH IN TO HER AT WWE
WRESTLING EVENT.
THE NAUSEA I FELT IN THE
EXACT MOMENT SHE MADE THAT
PROPOSITION TO ME ALL CAME
FLOODING BACK.
I LITERALLY HAD TO RUN TO
THE RESTROOM AND REGURGITATE
WHAT I HAD DONE ALL THOSE
YEARS BEFORE.
SHE IS BEYOND ANY REPROACH.
SHE IS A PROFESSIONALLAGE
TERRITORY.
LEAST TRUSTWORTHY HUMAN
BEING EVER CONCEIVED ON
GOD'S EARTH.
FOR HER TO BE LYING IN TO
MIKE PENCE ABOUT RELIGION
WHEN RELIGION HAS SOMEHOW
CREATED THIS MONSTER IS
BEYOND ANY SENSE OF REALISM
YOU COULD EVER WISH TO HAVE.
>> Tucker: WHAT A LIFE YOU
LEAD RUNNING INTO OMAROSA AT